bonjour merci jimmy bonjour philippe
jacq bonjour vers 5 heures rue monge aux
auditeurs avec la première et oui
candidats aux élections territoriales
pour le renouvellement de la ctm la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
les élections les dates des élections
c'est au mois de juin
cela fait un mois maintenant philippe
jacq que vous êtes entré en lice alors
depuis les retours que vous avez ici ou
là sont ils de nature à vous décourager
ou à vous encourager
alors ben regarde je l'avais rappelé
cela fait juste un mois que j'ai déclaré
que je serais peut-être de liste et
candidat aux élections territoriales les
retours positifs des martiniquaises des
martiniquais nous conforte l'équipe et
et moi même dans le choix que nous avons
fait de faire des propositions à la
population martiniquaise
c'est vraiment intéressant ce que nous
avons comme retour sur le terrain nous
avons déjà visité nombreuses communes
rencontré de nombreux martiniquaise et
de nombreuses martiniquaise et les
retours sont positifs ça traduit je
pense une envie de changement
une envie de faire de la politique
autrement de voir la politique autrement
et nous arrivons avec une une offre
politique nouvelle accompagnée d'une
nouvelle donne économique
je pense que ça correspond à une attente
avec des valeurs qui sont des valeurs de
solidarité des valeurs de justice
d'égalité mais aussi des valeurs qui
font appel au travail et à l'effort des
martiniquais nous allons l'évoqué un peu
plus en détail un peu plus précisément
même si je le rappelle
ça passe très vite nous n'avons pas
énormément de temps mais dites-moi bon
on vous avez entendu vous avez expliqué
que vous étiez déjà engagées au niveau
des municipales un des élections
municipales le bon vous intéresser à la
politique de depuis quelques temps mais
là qu'est ce qui vous à déterminer
pourquoi vous y allez et en tant que
tête de liste alors clairement la
situation de la martinique était déjà
dégradée si un choix que de mickey
sociale la crise qu vide est venu
rajouter une couche d'incertitude
d'inquiétude et avec
l'équipe parce que ça travaille l'équipe
c'est une équipe qui va compagne avec
l'équipe nous nous sommes dit qu'il
fallait faire des propositions aux
martiniquais faire en sorte que nous ne
trouvions pas dans le précipice nous
sommes au bord du précipice et il est
urgent je pense que c'est une des
dernières chances pour relancer la
machine
faire en sorte que l'économie reparte
nous avons un taux de chômage qui est un
taux de chômage inacceptable nous avons
des attentes sur la vie quotidienne des
martiniquais qui ne sont pas satisfaites
et tout ça nous conduit à penser que
nous a conduits à penser
il fallait y aller mais vous n'avez pas
d'expérience politique mais en qualité
parce que les avez une expérience
professionnelle certes tout le monde le
sait maintenant vous savez je fais à la
politique en étant précédent une
organisation patronale je fais la
politique en étant à présent nationaux
tomassi d'industrie mon expérience me
permet de dire que on a une idée assez
précise de ce qu'il faut faire pour
relancer la machine on a une idée des
obstacles et des freins que l'on
rencontre et nous voulons lever ces
freins
je crois aussi que des martiniquais rond
vie de deux changements ils ont déjà
essayé certain nombre d'hommes
politiques depuis trente ans il voit
bien que les choses n'avancent pas
n'avance pas comme elle devrait
je ne dis pas que rien n'a été fait je
pense qu'on peut aller plus vite on peut
aller plus loin en un mois vous avez
déjà une idée de ce qu'il ya un nom pour
la liste et puis est-ce que vous avez
déjà une idée de slogans parrainant de
snowdonia plusieurs il y en a il y en a
un pour matinée joke mais c'est un genou
avec mon nom y en a d'autres qui sont
que vous découvrirez au fur et à mesure
fera un petit teasing là dessus et et
permettez moi de ne pas dévoiler dès
aujourd'hui à la fois le nom de la liste
et le slogan mais matinik doc pro
matinée joke c'est quelque chose qui
revient c'est ça quand ça sonne ça
résonne même on le sent depuis d'autres
candidatures ont été déclarés depuis un
mois je veux dire on en est actuellement
à 7 à peu près avec notamment celle de
serge letchimy hier candidat à la
candidature mais enfin bon voilà
il est très probable qui sera candidat
on s'oriente vers une dizaine de listes
à peu près comment l'appréhendez vous
justement cette situation de réponse la
première c'est le signe d'un pays
démocratique
tout le monde peut être candidat tout le
monde a des propositions à faire et puis
le deuxième signe c'est que la situation
est complexe compliqué je pense que tout
le monde a envie d'apporter sa pierre et
et de permettre la reconstruction et le
développement de la martinique
moi je crois que cette dispersion des
candidatures ce nom est levé candidature
peut être plutôt une bonne chose alors
pour ça peut être ça peut être différent
les propositions sont nombreuses elles
sont multiples je n'entends pas beaucoup
de propositions aujourd'hui mais je
pense qu'elles seront nombreux et
multiples et si on arrivait à rassembler
tous ces propositions je pense que je ne
doute pas qu'il avait asséné qu'avance
alors on parlait du nom du slogan bon ça
c'est sur la forme et sur le fond
vraiment comment comptez vous composez
votre liste et avec qui notamment vous
aurez peut-être à éviter un écueil c'est
celui on y revient peut-être d'une image
un peu de technocratie est-ce que vous
parce que où est ce que je viens vous
voulez les incarner ce qu'on appelle un
peu la société civile j'entends ce que
vous des fellahs la sadc sera composé de
politique
deux mondes de la politique de politique
voit des gens qui font de la politique
il ya aussi des gens qui viennent du
monde associatif ont de la politique
mais les élus déjà vu vous avez vous
aurez les élus des gens connus mais on
ne veut pas municipaliser le scout à ce
scrutin territorial qui concerne
l'ensemble des martiniquais donc il ne
s'agit pas de faire un rassemblement de
d'élus municipaux c'est pas l'objet dont
je désirais des élus des gens de la
société civile ce que n'a pas souhaité
civile je veux pas trop l'expression
enfin on utilise des gens du monde
associatif avec des gens qui viennent de
la culture du sport mais aussi de
l'accompagnement des personnes en
situation de handicap parce que tout
notre programme est basé sur la
réduction des inégalités
je crois qu'il faut bien comprendre
qu'on comprenne que cette réduction des
inégalités est une nécessité
cet homme c'est impérieux que l'on
réduise les inégalités parce que
ces inégalités précisément elle
fragilise le lien social
elles font ne nous permettent pas
d'aller ensemble et donc je pense qu'il
faut les réduire les inégalités de
pouvoir d'achat les égalités
territoriale entre le nord et le sud le
centre entre les personnes en situation
de handicap et les personnes valides et
les personnes qui vivent des minima
sociaux les personnes qui sont dans
l'emploi je crois qu'il ya vraiment là
une attente forte des martiniquais et
nous avons des propositions à leur faire
mais il faut aussi je me disais
améliorer la vie des martiniquais avec
les problèmes de l'eau les problèmes
d'assainissement les problèmes de
transition
et puis pour tout ça il faut je pense et
je crois fortement développer les
productions martiniquaise qu'elles
soient agricoles qu'elles soient
industrielles et à l'homme ses sujets
d'accords mets mais comment avec quelle
méthodologie
c'est ce que j'ai envie de vous demander
et pour comment ferez vous pour éviter
éventuellement cet écueil
je dirais d'une image un peu un peu
technocrates le vouliez ou non nous
faisons et nous ferons d'animation
puller comment comptez-vous leur faisant
des propositions concrètes aux
martiniquais dimension populaire vous
savez vous vous l'ignorez peut-être mais
je suis moi issu d'un milieu modeste mes
grands parents étaient ouvriers à
l'école mon père était fonctionnaire
dépôt stage pas ou lyon je sais d'où je
viens et je n'ai jamais peur et vous
serez par les auteurs déjeuner le
déjeuner j'avais perdu j'aurais bientôt
électoraux je n'ai jamais rien dit alors
c'est vrai qu utiliser le créole aussi
par exemple concernant les crues yonne
mais je suis là jouent pas bouillon et
je suis de la ruralité je suis du
l'intérieur des terres
et donc je n'ai pas de problème avec le
contact avec la population certains
veulent me donner cette image de
technocrate de personnel run aide à la
population ce n'est pas le cas et
d'ailleurs dans les rencontres que je
fais depuis un mois ben j'ai pas de
difficulté à aller vers les gens ils
attendent je le répète et attendre des
propositions concrètes et attendent des
choses concrètes qui changeront leur vie
et nous nous avons des propositions à
faire alors des propositions c'est un
programme quelques propositions ou c'est
un projet de société que vous entendez
justement vous proposez il faut une
vision avec lui faut une vision pourra
décliner un projet
que une ambition forte gelée 10 et
réduit les inégalités mais c'est aussi
permettre aux martiniquais de retrouver
la fierté c'est important que l'on
trouve la fierté et nous travaillons à
un projet ouvert qui accueille tous les
martiniquais qui ont une vision partagée
qui font peuple et qui ont envie de voir
se développer ce pays et nous sommes
vraiment sur une dynamique de
construction de construction avec les
populations
alors si vous avez estimé utile à votre
sens un 2-2 de faire acte de candidature
pour la ctn pour le territoire
martiniquais ce c'est que vous estimez
que le bilan de l'équipe sortante n'est
pas n'est pas satisfaisant alors quelle
mesure lequel bien sûr je voulais dit il
y à une situation économique et sociale
qui était déjà dégradé la crise qu vide
est venu rajouter une couche
des choses ont été faites je ne dirais
pas que rien n'a été fait mais je pense
qu'on peut aller plus vite on peut aller
plus loin et l'ambition que nous avons
avec l'équipe qui m'accompagne c'est
d'aller plus vite d'aller plus loin et
de résoudre deux antennes résoudre les
problèmes des vendeurs en 2017 vous
critiquiez quand même hein l'équipe qui
était là depuis deux ans à peu près j'ai
retrouvé un extrait d'une interview with
et elle a su j'assume tout ce que j'ai
de 6,7 c'est en avançant qu a dit alors
qu'en est il exactement exactement vous
étiez en tant que président de la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie vous
regrettiez en 2017 que les études la ctm
n'écoute pas les propositions pour
financer l'économie locale alors depuis
2010 est quatre ans ce sont soit on
passait est ce que je vais dire que sur
ce point je ne retire pas un mot de ce
que j'ai à dire 2017
nous avons formulé des propositions
notamment pour l'accompagnement du
financement des porteurs de projets
martiniquais parce qu'il ya une richesse
il ya une envie forte de nombre de
martiniquais non le jeune martiniquais
notamment de se développer dans le
numérique dans les énergies
renouvelables et on n'a pas mis en place
depuis 10 ans dans ce pays
les outils de financement permettant à
tous les porteurs de projet artistique
est de réaliser le leur le rêve et leur
et leurs ambitions
et ça je pense que c'est un sujet qui
est qu'il faut remettre sur la table
parce que ça créera de l'emploi
ça permettra de faire revenir nos jeunes
on sait bien que la démographie qu'on
doit le prendre à bras le corps en mai
si on ne donne pas
à nos populations la possibilité de
revenir de réaliser chez elle ses rêves
et ses désirs
on n'avancera pas et le problème de
l'emploi je pense que c'est un problème
qu'il faut traiter parce que cela
participera à la réduction des
inégalités
elle avait dix minutes sont passées on
va conclure peut-être quand même avec
cette actualité
philip roth la plainte de bernard alioth
contre garcin malsa après des propos
tenus par garcin malsa donc l'homme
politique a maintenant qui est qui et
sans mandat mais enfin voilà bien connu
voilà dans une déclaration sur une radio
concurrente il le taxait de bernard
alioth de en partie ou pas du talent
enfin dans quelle mesure un responsable
de ce qui se passe au niveau de l'accord
négocié la chlordécone ma position est
très claire
certains demander des dérogations
d'autres les ont accordé ils sont
responsables et tous ceux qui auraient
utilisé la chlordécone
après la fin de théorisation doit
peut-être poursuivi je ne comprends pas
qu'on imagine que certains prétendent
nous parler de prescription moi je crois
que là-dessus des choses sont claires et
si on doit démontrer qu'il ya des
responsables et coupables il faudra
qu'il soit qu'il soit jugé
ma position là dessus est très clair
voilà je suis originaire la joue pas
bouillon donc quand je parle le
chlordécone
je parle avec mon coeur parce que j'ai
des amis qui étaient ouvriers agricoles
et qui en ont souffert dans leur chair
et certains sont même déjà disparu là
vous ètes semble-t-il sensible à à 7 ce
thème voilà alors j'ai dit plein de ces
plaintes pour diffamation de bernard
york contre garcin malsa voilà c'est la
fin de cette interview on vous
retrouvera un film donne puisque vous
êtes majeur est en campagne je
reviendrai je reviendrai avec plaisir
développer les éléments de mon programme
voila voila et ont des positions plus
longue et un débat oui certainement
voilà allez bonne journée bonne semaine
à toutes et à tous